en gros un kebab c'est un sandwich avec
de la viande grillée sur une broche qui
tourne à la verticale mais à partir de
là toutes les variantes sont permises en
France par exemple où l'on consomme
traditionnellement des viandes en sauce
les kebabs ont eu l'idée d'y mettre de
la sauce blanche pour s'adapter au
goulot local mais au Japon il est
présenté avec une sauce au curry en
Allemagne on le consomme plutôt dans un
sandwich garni de chou fermenté et au
Mexique la viande est mise dans une
galette de maïs accompagnée de guacamole
de la sauce à l'avocat même chose pour
les viandes il y en a pour tous les
goûts agneau poulet bœuf
même pour le pain il y a le choix pain
pita baguette tacos